This week,
you're reading hospitals,
sketches,
the short
and in some ways extraordinary little novel written by Louisa May Alcott based
upon her.
Well,
Lisa May Alcott of little women fame if you happen to have grown up on that
book.
Daughter of Bronson Alcott,
a famous and extremely eccentric new England reformer and utopian,
but she went to war as a young nurse,
couldn't stay away,
and she kept her sketches about her experiences of a young woman confronting the
horror of civil war hospitals.
This is a photograph of,
it is not.
Louisa may Alcott.
I don't think I have one of those young nurses sitting on a civil war hospital
in 1863
probably a writing a letter.
They spend a lot of their time writing letters for sick or dying or wounded
soldiers.
Okay.
I think what you can find an Alcott's novel among other things,
it's almost like a descriptive documentary novel.
It's almost like she summed up or diary
is the human encounter,
particularly a woman's,
a young woman's encounter with what war does to the human body,
the human psyche,
to human beings
now,
good Lord.
It is.
18 years ago,
Ken Burns produced,
can it really be a series on public television called the civil war?
As every opening of it says,
brought to you by General Motors,
nine episodes in 11 hours garnered the largest public television audience ever.
Um,
the estimate was that the first time through about 30 million Americans watched
it then it's been rerun many,
many times.
I went to Germany to teach for a year in 1992 and 93 and when I arrived in the
fall of 1992 on German national television,
they were running the Ken Burns film series,
all 11 hours of it dubbed into German
and was weird
because there was one male voice and one female voice for all the voices.
Of course,
one of the tricks or one of the techniques,
one of the quite brilliant techniques of burns,
his film was the many different voices he used garrison Keillor for Walt
Whitman,
Sam Waterston for Abraham Lincoln,
et Cetera,
voices that you,
in many ways they're Americans in any ways we're comfortable with in their
living room.
They knew Sam Waterston didn't him as well as I know him now from law and order,
but they knew garrison Keillor's voice.
And when garrison Keillor came on every night,
it was Walt Whitman.
At any rate,
I was Spanish at the reaction in Germany.
There were articles in the paper,
editorials and so on and so on.
I had one German student come up to me one day after watching an episode of it
and listening to one of my lectures and he said,
why were there so many sunsets and moonrises and that documentary film?
I said,
wow.
He caught me off guard.
It's a watch.
A good question probably because burns is a sentimental film maker
and as a great deal of sentiment in the structure and the music and in the mode
of that film series.
And I defy you to watch one or two hours and not be harming the show.
Can farewell and the shower the next morning.
Uh,
da Da da Da.
Um,
uh,
it is a haunting violin.
It wasn't as some people say,
written for that film series.
It's much older.
At any rate it is assigned in the course,
at least major parts of it.
You can access it.
I'm actually going to assign you episodes two through nine.
That's eight out of the nine.
If you skip one or two,
only the gods will,
no,
I'm sure.
Yeah.
But they will know
it is all available on the Internet at Yale to the film archive.
And perhaps you,
how many of you have done this before for courses?
Fabulous.
You've done this.
All right.
I checked this morning.
The Url,
if you can read this,
I don't know if you can read this.
Can you read this?
Yes,
yes.
In the front.
In the back.
No.
How about now?
Whoa.
yale.edu/collabs see labs.
I don't know what the something that stands for that's for MACs.
They tell me that this is better on pcs,
the easier on pcs and macs and you might have to download a patch to do it on a
Mac.
True,
false.
Don't know
anybody.
Done it recently and of course
help
you all raised your hands.
You've done this before.
Don't remember.
It's also easy.
Okay,
good.
Uh,
over the next five,
including spring break week.
You're in Jamaica spring break week.
You can access Ken Burns film,
you can be humming and the shogun farewell in the shower with somebody in
Jamaica.
That's terrible.
The best laugh I've had in this course.
You're just like everybody else.
At any rate,
that's the Url,
ladies and gentlemen,
and then you,
you know you need use your net id to access it.
If you have any problem with this,
let us know immediately and we will help you.
It is assigned and we're going to discuss it.
I love a final exam question.
Don't always use it.
That actually draws upon him as a source.
Just thought I'd say that.
Okay.
There also is in the syllabus this week.
Of course,
a very vague reading.
You're reading hospital sketches which is short,
but then it says selective choices.
There's select select selections from about 50 pages of documents and the gap
book and about 40 pages of dispatchers and documents and letters by Lincoln and
the Lincoln reader.
We're going to pin that down for you at our lunch today and you'll be fired.
An email before this afternoon,
uh,
perhaps,
in May,
may be individualized by your teaching assistant as to which of those documents
you might especially want to concentrate on.
But in those two sections of Ganapathy and,
and Johnson,
if you haven't looked yet and you should,
you get link a day by day.
In some cases you get Lincoln's orders and dispatches to his generals,
his attempt to become the war president,
including that first document in that section where Lincoln Lazy right after the
disaster at bull run,
he lays out nine or 10 very direct orders all beginning with the word.
Let,
let that be this letter,
be that let to be this,
let there be that.
And you also find in these documents,
specially in the Ganapathy reader,
some of those incredibly megalomaniac letters by George Be Mcclellan.
If ever there was a more vain character in American military history and
political history,
well there've been a lot thing characters in American political history,
God knows.
But if ever anybody left,
more egregiously vein,
utterly self serving,
okay.
Letters and dispatch is about his own sense of self glory.
It is Mcclellan who by all rights probably should have been court martialed
but wasn't.
That's another story.
We'll come back to
mine.
Eyes have seen the glory of the coming of the Lord.
He has loose the fateful lightning with his terrible swift sword.
He is trampling out the vintage where the Grapes of Wrath are stored.
It's possibly the most famous poetry in American music.
It's also apocalyptic.
Some would say purple
and it's blood.
Hey Julia Ward.
How wrote the famous battle hymn of the republic in early 1862 while overlooking
I going camp money,
huge encampment of the Union army near Washington
and she stayed until sunset and saw the fires,
which she called the watch fires
and she wrote the great apocalyptic pay on of the civil war.
We will come back to this question especially next week when we deal with the,
the story.
The problem with emancipation at the beginning of this war,
as we'll see in a moment,
most people expected something short,
might've been just beer,
a lot of fun.
The summer outing and adventure chance to whip some Yankees.
Maybe shoot a rebel too.
Yeah.
But if it became very long at all,
and that's the point,
it became very long at all.
It's aims,
its goals,
its strategies,
it's purposes would have to chain.
It's why the thinking people of 1861 feared along war Lincoln most definitely
and most prominently he feared what as he said in his,
uh,
Mommy said it in the second inaugural.
He set it also earlier in his annual message at the end of 1861 he feared a long
quote remorseless revolutionary struggle because a long remorseless
revolutionary struggle would have very different fundamental results in that
second inaugural.
Again,
one of those famous passages from that speech,
Lincoln said,
all had hoped that was at the end of it all had hoped.
He said for quote,
a result,
less fundamental and astounding,
but because of this war will not be short.
It will become all out and total depending on whose interpretation and argument
you accept the terms of what is modern total war.
And we'll come back to that question.
The results would become fundamental
and transform it to
now.
Oops.
Sorry.
Okay.
We always still titles from
Julia Ward.
How,
just like we do from Lincoln,
that's actually a photograph of
bull run creek.
I don't know.
It could be a creek anywhere.
I know,
but trust me,
that's bull run creek.
Yeah.
There were 523 west point graduates who fought in the Mexican war
and that war back in 1846 to 48 it'd become a kind of,
if you like military primer for so many of them
and the vast majority of those would end up in the civil war on both sides.
Ulysses grant,
class of 43 William Tecumseh Sherman,
class of 40 Williams one winfield Scott Hancock,
class of 44 George Thomas,
class of 40 George has made class of 35 Joseph Hooker,
class of 30 John Sedgwick,
class of 37 Joseph,
he Johnston,
most notably Robert E.
Lee,
class of 1829 versus business class
later commandant of West Point.
They'd all learned to kind of warrior culture if you like.
They're all taking a very deep and abiding oath.
It was a very difficult thing to do for west point graduates on the southern
side to abandon that oath and go with their states.
But of course many,
many,
many of them did.
As Oliver Otis Howard,
well West Point graduate later Union Corps commander lost his arm in the
Petersburg campaign and later first leader head of the Freedmen's bureau after
the civil war and for whom Howard University is named
said quote,
probably no other place existed where men grappled more sensitively with the
troublesome problems of succession.
No kidding.
Now
the numbers of this,
um,
there was a kind of a stampede of west point cadets back to the south at least
to a certain degree.
And Ohio Cadet named Tali McCray wrote to his sweetheart is 18,
April,
1861.
This has been an eventful week in the history of West Point.
There has been such a stampede of cadets as was never known before.
30 to resign and were relieved from duty on Monday,
April 22 and since then,
enough to increase the number to more than 40.
All right now,
few cadets from any southern state left here
in all 74 southern cadets resigned and were dismissed for refusing to take the
oath of allegiance to the United States,
but 21 southern cadets from slave states remained and would eventually fight for
the union.
This was a far higher proportion of loyalist then southern students at Harvard,
Yale,
or Columbia at Princeton,
not one southern student remained at the college,
so the old southern tradition at Princeton make no mistake.
There are many extraordinary witnesses to these breakups,
that west point.
Here's just one of them.
Okay.
The Cadet George Armstrong Custer class of 1861 that Custer recalled walking
sentinel duty in June of 61 and seeing 15 defecting southern cadets marching
toward a steamboat landing on the Hudson.
Yeah,
I quote him too far off to exchange verbal ado.
Even if military discipline had permitted,
they caught sight of me a step by step.
I reluctantly paid the penalty of offended regulations.
That's why he's doing this guard duty and raise their hats and token farewell to
which first casting my eyes about to see that no watchful,
superior wasn't view.
I responded by bringing my musket to a present.
Yeah.
Customer would later be proud of how many southerners he had killed.
The next whole section of this course,
I want to suggest some questions that we want to hope that you will leave you
with the answers for
and you can write these down and hold me to it if you want.
We can disagree about those answers,
but that's what history is ultimately for one.
Why did the north wind this war?
Two,
why did the south lose it?
Three,
what did making war and experiencing it mean to common soldiers,
to officers,
to their families,
to the women left at home and the women who went to the front.
Yeah.
How did the war for,
how did the war on leash or reinforce or reshape 19th century values and
attitudes on Americans of the 1860s confronted war on this scale?
80% of all white males in the American south between the age of 16 and 45 will
be in the army.
80% in the northern states,
50% much higher population of all white males between 18 and 45 will be in the
army or the navy.
You imagine if we had 50% of the American,
let's just,
let's just count the white males in the United States today under arms,
through a draft.
Whole lot of you wouldn't be here.
What did five what did the war itself mean?
On both sides?
It's cars.
It's purpose.
That developing sense of the reason people fight.
What was it about
six?
What were the wars results?
What were its consequences
towards have meanings that we are obliged to discern?
Uh,
yeah.
Seven.
Why were the slaves free?
How did emancipation come when it came the way it came?
Eight
was it the American civil war?
A second American revolution?
Yes.
No,
maybe in between.
Is it the wrong term?
Is there a better one?
Nine.
What is it?
The place of this pivotal transformative event
in America's national memory
and 10
God,
I hope we can answer some of these.
Was the civil war a just war.
Okay.
When the war came
back to that
little picture of bull run in a moment,
but when the war came,
of course
Americans had to now decide how to fight a war they had never mobilized for like
they're gonna mobilize in this war.
Although at the beginning,
no one really had any clue of the scale of the mobilization in industry and
resources and transportation and in human power that the war would would bring.
Let's examine just for a moment this question of union advantages and southern
advantages,
strengths and weaknesses on both sides at the outset of the war and even through
it,
it has a great deal to do with ultimately explaining union victory and
confederate defeat,
although it is not by itself and explanation,
the north didn't just win the war because it had more industrial capacity.
Or as Ken Burns has Shelby Foote say at one point,
a star of his film has Shelby Foote.
Say at one point in the film,
the north fought that war with one hand behind his back.
Bullshit Shelby.
They really did not fight that war with one hand behind their back.
Uh,
but it helps make a nice explanation or the beginnings of a nice explanation for
southern defeat and were many union advantages.
Let me just tick off several.
First in finances were the north had and most of this in New York City and a
couple other cities had four times the bank deposits as the southern states.
Even though most of the southern states had their bank deposits in northern
banks in manufacturing,
there were 110,000 manufacturing establishments in the northern states with 1.2
million industrial workers in 1860 the north had four times.
Yeah.
Oh,
I already said that.
The bank deposits for give me the north had
the north,
excuse me.
There were as many factories in the north as there were industrial workers in
the south
and the neighborhood of a hundred and a hundred thousand or so small
manufacturing industrial workers of one kind and another in southern towns and
cities.
The northern states had that many manufacturing establishments.
80% of all industrial capacity in the United States.
We're in the free stage
one Connecticut County,
new Haven County,
this town,
and it's county produced firearms valued at 10 times the entire,
the entire southern capacity to produce in 1860 now,
the sound's going to improve that greatly through the tredegar ironworks in
Richmond in particular and other places,
but new haven,
Connecticut produce 10 times the firearms is an entire south put together in
1860 those shelves of some of those old factories in this town that are no
longer factories were gun factories.
Man,
did they get rich during the civil war?
Okay,
and transportation.
80% of all railroad miles in the United States,
the former United States,
we're in the northern states of the 470 locomotives made in the United States by
1860 only 19 of them had been made in the south.
North had the vast,
vast majority of skilled mechanics who worked on railroads.
The North tended to have uniform gauges to their railroads three or four feet
wide to the track.
In the south.
They had this ridiculous problem,
frankly,
and they will not solve it very quickly.
That the south build is railroads haphazardly,
state by state,
by state,
and all kinds of different gauges.
Three and a half feet here,
four feet therefore and a half feet there.
You'd go into one town with a railroad gauge.
This one width,
but it goes out the other side of town of the gauges,
another width.
Okay.
You had the switch silica motors and switch trains.
As ridiculous as that sounds.
If I'm not in a hurry.
What a misery that would cause another northern advantage was simply in
manpower.
Just to look at the population numbers,
the population of the North was approximately 22 and a half million people in
the population of the south was slightly over 9 million white people.
Okay.
And about four and a half million black people.
Yeah,
about 4.2 million of whom were slaves.
The other 250 to 300,000 who were free blacks.
Northern states produced 94% of all cloth in the United States in 1860,
93% of all pig iron and on and on and on boats,
ships,
it's all 80,
90,
95% in favor of the north.
William Tecumseh Sherman,
uh,
was sitting in New Orleans where he was stationed when succession occurred in
the war broke out and they prolate 1861 and according to his testimony,
he said to his friend who had actually been at west point,
buddy of his,
he warned him and he said,
quote,
no nation of agriculturalists ever made war on a nation of mechanics and
survived.
Yeah,
it's very prescient.
But I don't want you to think that you,
the north,
the confederate success or victory was somehow that the outset because of all
these economic,
financial,
industrial advantages,
okay,
the north had certain political advantages.
It did not have to create a government.
You'd already had one
at a function in government.
Now 11 of those states are no longer be represented.
There going to be gone.
But there a function in US federal government,
the south has to create that government overnight.
And it has to create it out of a political culture rooted in states' rights and
localism.
And furthermore,
and I,
this is a very important point.
The North had a functioning political party system.
There were still functioning Democrats and the north very strong in certain
pockets of the norm.
They will be a genuine opposition party to Lincoln's Republicans during the war.
They will make a comeback in the congress in 80 62,
they got clobbered in 1860.
The South doesn't have a party system.
South has a one party system.
They appointed Jefferson Davis.
The south will not hold the general election for the presidency and vice
presidency during this war.
Why is that important?
Why wouldn't you have a functioning political party system you way?
You have a way of organizing power in organizing patronage,
in organizing a loyalty.
When a Jefferson date will see this soon.
Thursday want to Jefferson Davis is greatest problems and biggest crises
throughout the war is trying to get the southern states to go along with various
confederate federal policies,
knee and uh,
he will fail it much of that
now south was not without advantages.
Look at a map.
You could argue that the south had a great advantage of geography if the user
didn't.
Well,
the south is a huge expanse of territory.
Huge.
Thousands of,
what is it?
A almost a 2000 mile coastline,
a 1500 mile coastline,
I believe if you add up,
you know,
Florida all the way up to Virginia.
And when Lincoln announced the call coffers for 75,000 volunteers in April of
[inaudible] 61 he also announced a naval blockade of the entire south.
Yeah.
Oh,
this will forever be a tricky legal story and an interesting constitutional
problem.
Lincoln says,
the southern states could not constitutionally secede from the union.
They were not there for legitimate belligerent.
He was not in any way recognize the thing,
recognizing them as a legitimate government,
but oh,
by the way,
he was gonna put a total naval blockade on them.
Nevertheless.
Now foreign countries,
especially the Great Britain will look at this and say,
well,
you may not do the session you may not think is constitutional and your country
and may not call the confederacy of belligerent,
but you sure as hell a treating them like one.
Okay.
At any rate,
a blockade around that entire coastline will never be easy.
And we know that it was a very porous and the first year,
even in the second year of the war through 1862 very porous,
but the naval blockade eventually was relatively successful by 1864 and into
early 1865
okay.
What is a huge expanse of territory?
The south had rivers that could use and it will use them effectively of course.
So the north,
once they invade the sound.
Okay.
Geography was an advantage to the southern cause.
As many military historians have argued ever since if and when they stayed on
the defensive,
when they chose to invade the north,
as Lee will twice to fateful invasions,
the one resulting it emptied them in September of 62 and the other get his
Bergen July of 63 he was giving up that advantage of the defensive position,
forcing the larger armies of the north to come to them and attack on southern
ground on the southern soil.
This has always been a debate.
Had the south remained utterly defensive in this war.
Could the north of stood it hell out long enough?
Thirdly,
you could argue that in the south has an advantage and its cause or its purpose
and perhaps it first,
maybe they did or even later after a terrible degree of war weariness.
It said in the argument is simply that the south didn't have to win the war.
They didn't have to conquer the north.
They simply had to fight long enough as an insurgent.
They were the insurgent,
they w the confederacy.
It was an insurgency.
Let's use that term.
It's exactly what they were.
If they could hold out long enough and force the North into a a degree of war
weariness and to some kind of economic trauma,
yeah,
they might just sue for peace.
After all.
The goal of the confederacy was national independence.
Some,
some have said their cars was clearer,
less abstract.
Defense of the homeland.
Defense of hearth is in some ways less abstract then defense of the union or the
constitution or the social order.
How many of you want your sons to die for the social order?
Maybe you do a lot for me to say.
If they'd stayed on the defensive,
they and they know this,
uh,
this is one of those tests.
The questions about Robert E.
Lee is legacy.
They had an advantage here.
Now have this new relatively new invention.
Thousands,
thousands upon thousands of which were made in this town.
And I was the rifle musket
until the 18,
late 1840 [inaudible] into the 1850s almost all firearms,
all muskets were smooth bore
the shell or the bullet or the [inaudible] ball that came out of them came out
of just a barrel.
It was flat on the inside and it would only go a hundred to 200 yards,
200 yards maximum.
But with the creation of the rifled must get an eventually rifled cannon.
A rifled muskets could hit something as far as 800 yards away.
It doesn't mean you could see what you were shooting at,
but it was extremely deadly at two to 300 yards now.
Okay.
And Award.
It's still going to be fought with these hideous old Napoleonic tactics of
lining up men by the thousands arm to arm,
elbow to elbow,
and simply moving across fields.
The defensive position with the rifle musket was a huge advantage if used
many have said over and over the south head and superior general ship and the
first,
especially two years of the war,
and I don't think there's much question that they did.
And then of course,
some have argued that the south simply had the Yeoman soldier.
Better soldiers.
Yeah.
Better men.
So cold.
Now they thought they did.
And let me give you a couple of illustrations of that
they'd thought they did in their rhetoric and in their war fever
of 1861
one young confederate officer rode home from the summer of 1861 he said,
just throw three or four shows among those blue belt,
the Yankees and they'll scatter like sheep,
so it was the theory.
It was not the improved arm but the improved man wrote Governor Henry Wise of
Virginia which would win the day.
He's writing this in 1861 let brave men advance with Flint locks and old
fashioned bayonets on the pop and Jay's of northern cities and he would answer
forward with his life at the Yankees,
the Yankees,
he says,
we'll break and run.
Yankees won't fight or so was the theory.
Now I don't know times,
I suppose that was an advantage.
There were,
it was a certain warrior culture in the south.
There were perhaps more hunters per capita in the south and maybe in the north,
but don't make much of that one.
The south had awesome problems,
low to fight this war as well,
and let me tick them off quickly.
They all have a tremendous problem of supply.
As the war gets bigger,
Johnny Reb will never be very well clad,
never very well fed,
always relying on captured blankets and captured boots and captured food.
Okay.
And even captured and medical supplies at times in the south.
They will truly,
in a biblical sense,
after make plow shares into swords.
Okay.
They actually accomplished amazing things in the creation of weapons of
ordinance,
of gunpowder,
of shells by the thousands,
almost overnight.
They will also buy a lot from Great Britain from French to some extent.
And much of that we'll get in through the blockade and the first two years they
had a huge disadvantage of not having a navy.
They had then somehow create a navy,
and we'll come back to this later.
When we look at the role of Europe in this,
they will go to Britain and try to buy ships and they will ironclads
rims and ultimately battleships that will prey upon and destroyed hundreds of
union ships.
And then you might say that they had a real political disadvantage,
I guess I've already mentioned it and that they were born of a state's rights
impulse and overnight now they have to try to centralize the government to fight
a highly centralized coordinated war over a vast thousand mile front.
Yeah,
and Georgians are supposed to cooperate with Virginians are supposed to
cooperate with Tennesseans,
are supposed to cooperate with our Kansans,
didn't always work,
and last but not least,
would slavery being an advantage or a disadvantage in the south wharf?
To some degree it wasn't advantage and thousands upon thousands of American
slaves will be put to work for the confederate military for the confederate and
industry.
If you visited the confederate army from 1861 on,
if it was above a thousand men,
you would see plenty of black guys and some black women.
If you were on a a southern train by 1863 you'd see plenty of black workers on
that train.
Most of them slaves.
If you were in a field hospital in Georgia by 63 and 64 during Sherman's march,
if you were in a confederate hospital,
you'd see plenty of black nurses.
About 40% of all the nurses and confederate hospitals from 63 and Georgia were
slave women.
Okay.
They were impressed into confederate service by the thousands.
So there's an advantage in that.
But I think as we'll see next week,
slavery ultimately
was the Achilles heel of the confederate war effort because once the union
leadership,
and that's going to happen,
it's going to take a year into the war,
but that's going to happen by 1862 and certainly 63 will come to see you that
the only way they can truly win the war is by destroying slavery.
And once the union war effort becomes an effort to destroy the social structure
of the south,
including its labor system and a in a,
in an effort to destroy slavery,
it becomes an all out and total war of conquest.
Now quickly to the extent there was an opening grand strategy,
uh,
soon to be abandoned.
It was this
winfield Scott,
the old rough and ready as he was known,
the old general,
the Mexican war.
He's very ancient by now.
He's 80 years old.
He's begging,
he's fat and he's in mobile,
but he was the general of the army and he came up with what he called the
Anaconda plan.
The Anaconda plan was basically to envelop the south surrounded by a naval
blockade,
use gunboats to penetrate the rivers down the Ohio,
the Mississippi,
the Missouri of necessary from the West and up those rivers of Virginia and down
the coast of the Carolinas and in effect,
suffocate the south from outside.
Yeah.
Over time,
my ticket year,
I'd even take two years.
The idea here was to surround the south
and to force them.
Ultimately tonight,
he's not just see the error of their ways,
but to see that they had no chance to win.
This was a plan.
Now that would not invade the south with major armies and seek major battlefield
victories.
It was almost a kind of in an economic plan to win a war.
It would take time,
patience,
and ever growing navy,
but the American people wouldn't have it.
The northern people wouldn't have it.
They want an army forming around Washington DC in April,
May and June 861 to move to act.
Horace Greeley,
most important editor of most important newspaper in the United States,
New York Herald Tribune and New York publish the famous headline onto Richmond
or forward to Richmond.
It said,
attack that confederate army,
stop the insurgency,
whipped them once and the rebellion,
punish his leaders and get this thing over before the end of summer.
Now,
the problem here is not unlike,
think about it,
the problem in the American revolution,
if the British could have ended that American insurgency in the American
revolution quickly in the first year or two,
instead of letting these American armies under George Washington and others keep
retreating away from them and not engaging in any real pitched battles and
continuing to give up their cities and retreat,
England and England and England,
the British or the Americans would not have won their revolution.
Okay?
As long as the confederate armies could exist,
the confederacy could exist if indeed we interpreted as a revolutionary
insurgency.
And ultimately that is virtually how they will interpret themselves.
And hence we can see that if this war last very long,
it lasted frankly beyond one year,
it had all the potential of becoming a war of conquest all out in total,
requiring the destruction of the southern infrastructure and southern society.
Now,
both sides in this war now get around a bull run,
and when the war broke out in the west and a moment,
both sides in this war will engage in conscription.
They will create the draft.
For the first time in American history,
the confederates were first to do it.
The first conscription act in American history has passed in April of 1862 by
the confederate government.
It said that all able bodied men,
18 to 35 later raised to 45 would be conscripted into three years of service.
They allowed the hiring of a substitute which led to the charge of Elitism,
which was accurate.
There were brokers and all kinds of dishonest substitutes.
One man is alleged to have sold himself 20 times for the bounty that he got paid
to get out.
There were exemptions in the confederate conscription,
public servants,
ministers,
teachers,
editors,
nurses,
factory in railroad workers,
miners and telegraph operators.
Among the confederate troops out at the front,
they called these people bomb proof positions
and then worst of all,
and the confederate conscription law in 1863 they what was known as the 20 Negro
Law.
If you own 20 or more slaves,
you were exempt from service.
The reason for that was the deep fear setting in an 1862 across the south that
have all these white men,
80% of white males in the south will be in the army.
If you look,
if all these white men left the plantations,
that would be black men left on the plantations running the place.
Any man who had 20 more 20 or more slaves was exempt if he chose to be.
This will cause tremendous resentment and the confederate armies and ultimately
one of become one of the causes of desertion.
Yeah.
The union conscription law came later.
It didn't come until early 63
it drafted every able bodied man 20 years of age to 45 years of age.
It had its exemptions were more limited.
You could escape if you could find a substitute and pay $300
hence the charge,
not inaccurate.
That in the north,
this people's wars,
Lincoln called it this war to save democracy became a rich man's war and a poor
man's fight.
Generous bounties were paid if you enlisted in Indian,
only about 6% of all the union forces in the civil war.
We're drafting
the social pressure in some communities since regiments were formed locally was
tremendous,
especially in the first two years.
Okay.
Approximately 20% of all confederates were draftees.
Only 6%
of union troops.
Now,
I only have a few minutes left and I'm sorry for that,
but I wanted to lay out our aims and goals here,
but let me leave you with how this first battle of the war actually came and
we'll pick it up.
They're thirsty.
Makes as much sense.
Thursday along that creek.
You can see the picture here
and extraordinary photograph taken actually taken an 1862
of four children.
Two of them were in
what are probably the union copies,
hats
and seven union cavalryman cross the creek.
I was though there at attention for the photographer.
It's a remarkable picture of,
it seems to me the influence of war on the young,
but it was along that creek on the 21st of July,
1861 a Sunday afternoon at the collision of amateur armies occurred in the first
major battle of the civil war.
Came about Lincoln under the pressure of public opinion,
forced his command.
Erwin Mcdonnell to move this army that was not very well trained.
It wasn't prepared to fight.
They hadn't even been taught how to retreat,
which they're about to demonstrate.
Mcdowell complained to Lincoln.
He says,
people can't fight that,
that that we don't have.
We have.
We have learned this.
We haven't learned that.
We're not ready.
Don't make us move.
And Lincoln said,
I have no choice.
You must move.
And he wrote to Mcdowell and he said,
quote,
you are green.
It is true,
but they are agreeing.
You are all green.
I like,
oh thanks a lot.
Mcdonald probably said an offy marched about 20 miles south and west of
Washington to collide with this confederate army that had been forming off for
three months in northern Virginia,
threatening us capital.
It was a summer outing,
a couple hundred civilians and carriage as many of them congressmen and their
wives and families,
God encourages peck.
Picnic lunches went down to watch the battle.
They,
they sat on hillsides to watch this spectacle.
Let me just stay far enough away.
You wouldn't see any blood.
You're going to be some casualties,
but that's they're supposed to be.
They took picnics
to yes to US Congress from Roland up captured and spend the next year in a
Richmond prison.
Yeah,
it was a,
it was a crazy battle.
It lasted only three hours and both commanding generals Beauregard on the
confederate side and Mcdonald on the union side had the same plan,
a fake to the right and a move to the left.
This was old fashioned stuff.
Now that they both had managed to pull it off and they're men have known what
they were doing that it's simply moved each other around and the confederate
army could have walked up into Washington,
but nothing came off as planned.
At first,
the Union forces took oh several hundred yards of the field that looked like in
these field glasses people were using.
This is going to be another union victory.
First clashed with the Union victory,
send a confederate army,
retreating back into Virginia and the rebellion.
Then as fast as that happened,
it turned around and the counter attack came.
It was led by a general named Thomas Jackson,
who gets his name at bull run,
stonewall Jackson.
More on him later
and suddenly these union soldiers knew nothing of retreat.
They threw down rifles,
they ran through creeks and found the first road they could.
They broke ranks
and they retreated.
Many of them running the rest of that afternoon and through into the evening
back to Washington DC in utter defeat and retreat.
It was so that the wagons and the case ons of the artillery started running over
men Albin tours.
J later to become the most important novelist and writer of the reconstruction
era was badly wounded.
He had a shoulder smashed and broken by the wheel of a case on and the retreat
from bull run and it would have to leave the war for a year.
He'll return to it,
but he'd never be able to use one of his shoulders very effectively.
Bull run first bull run was a complete confederate victory.
A union defeat.
A union army retreated into the national capitol,
a shock to the country.
The casualties were this 460 killed on the union side.
Over 1100 wounded and 1300 men missing for the next month
total of almost 2,900 casualties and the confederate side,
387 killed,
1500 wounded and only 13 missing about 1900 total casualties
in the wake of bull run.
Lincoln brings George Beam McClellan,
this vain,
glorious but handsome is hell smart west point graduate of 34 years old to the
White House.
He'd had a couple small little victories out in western Virginia,
whether it'd been a couple of clashes with the,
with southern troops a brought this gold sash wearing young officer to the White
House and gave him command of this army that they then name the army of the
Potomac
and the army was being increased daily now with hundreds and hundreds and
thousands of troops from the north and Mcclellan,
put him into camp camp Brightwood among others.
Huge camp bill outside of Washington,
and he'll start training them for months and months and months,
and the civil war got longer and longer and longer,
and is not going to move that army for another 10 months,
nine months until the late spring of 1862 meanwhile,
the war is going to break out in the West too,
and we'll return to that Thursday.